i'm going to share with you
the real underlying cause of abdominal
pain
now i've never done a video on this
specific link so
this might be new information for you
i've had some serious abdominal pain for
years and i searched out everywhere i
could to find
how to fix it i've done colon cleanses
i've done combination of enemas and
cleanses and i've been on every single
diet to try to fix it looking back now i
was simply missing
some crucial basic information that
you're going to learn today
unfortunately when you go to the doctor
right now with abdominal pain
you'll get a diagnosis
and then you're going to get management
of that
symptom okay you're good they're going
to manage your symptom there's not going
to be a lot of getting to the root cause
and fixing it it's going to be more
managing it with a medication now
anything that i say is not meant to
invalidate your medical doctor so check
with your doctor before doing what i'm
going to tell you maybe you'll get a
diagnosis like biliary dyskinesia which
basically means there's a sludge in your
bile ducts okay
things aren't moving
bile is not moving it's kind of stuck
there and when we're dealing with
abdominal pain we're really dealing with
pressure from gas
fluids
fecal matter
or food
backing up somewhere causing pressure in
some of the plumbing going on whether
it's from the liver to the gallbladder
or the pancreas
to the small intestine or maybe it's in
your large intestine maybe you get a
diagnosis diabetic gastroparesis which
basically is a fancy term for the nerves
are so damaged in your digestive system
that everything is very very slow so the
transit time of food going through these
tubes is very sluggish which is going to
cause a lot of bloating and pain maybe
you'll get a diagnosis with gastritis or
heartburn or acid reflux or indigestion
or maybe you'll get a diagnosis with
gastro esophageal reflux disorder which
means this little valve on the top of
the stomach is not closing so food is
kind of backing up through your
esophagus and maybe you're diagnosed
with an ulcer
regardless of what condition you have
there's something very very simple and
very powerful that i'm going to show you
but in order to put things back into
place
you have to understand some basic
anatomy
and where things are in location to your
abdomen where you have pain because
that will give you a clue okay
okay i have my friend right here
if we take a look at the abdominal area
and we break it down into sections we
have this upper right part right here
you have the middle upper part right
here and the left upper part right here
okay so over here on the right side you
have the liver and the gallbladder and
you have the connections okay those are
called ducts like your bile ducts okay
in the center you have the stomach
okay and you also have this thing that's
crossing over called the pancreas all
right
and then on the left side you have part
of the pancreas and then you have the
spleen over here and then right in the
center right here you have the small
intestine okay and it connects to the
large intestine that comes up through
here crosses over and comes down this
way and then in the middle part right
here on the right side okay a little
lower than the upper part you have the
kidney area you have in the little
connection between the kidney and the
bladder it's called the ureter
and then on the left side you have the
kidney over here with the ureter and of
course right on top of the kidneys you
have the adrenals and they're way back
over here and then in the lower part
right here in the center you have the
uterus and you have a prostate in that
area and then if you're female in the
lower left and lower right you'll have
ovaries so in other words if you know
where you have pain and you know the
organs that are connected
then it's pretty easy to kind of narrow
it down the problem is that
the pancreas
crosses over
from not just the left side but the
middle
and even the right side so sometimes
it's a little confusing and sometimes
the gallbladder if there's stones can
cause pain a little lower and sometimes
the kidney stone can cause pain a little
bit higher up so there are certain
things you can do to differentiate
between the two but i just wanted to
give you a little orientation of where
certain organs are located so the first
thing i want to cover something very
very common
yet it's not well known okay and that is
this problem in the right upper quadrant
right through in here okay you have the
gallbladder you have the liver in this
area and i kind of drew a picture out
right here
typically the symptoms that are related
to gallbladder are bloating burping and
belching but it can definitely be
abdominal distension or pain so we have
the liver here that makes
bile okay so bile
comes down from a little tube through
here and gets stored in the gallbladder
and then when you eat the gallbladder
contracts it's a storage bile
and now that bile can squeeze into this
little tube down here okay
and go into the small intestine to mix
with
the food that just came out of the
stomach
and then with the help of the pancreas
certain enzymes specifically lipase
which digests lipids which can help
further break down the fat into smaller
particles so we have this
bile that breaks down fat to a certain
level and then the
enzyme lipase breaks it down to smaller
levels so now you can digest and use the
fats as in your fat soluble vitamins
omega-3 fatty acids
all the fatty acids okay so that's those
two fluids right there now of course you
can have a gallstone right so
some people have gallstones some people
don't
but a lot of people
have
sluggishness within this
duct right here in other words
the bile material is like sludge
and that's an actual medical thing and
it can back up
into these tubes and cause tremendous
amount of pain
that then can refer
up to your right shoulder and even the
right scapula and the right trap through
here now this little duct right here
also joins with the with the pancreatic
duct or tube okay it joins right here so
a blockage in this area can not only
back up material back up within the
liver causing
pain up into the right side but it can
back up into the pancreas causing
pancreatitis or pain that goes in the
middle part or even the left side that
then can refer to your left shoulder so
it can be a little complex but this
problem is very very common
and the real cause of this is simply a
lack of bile okay because when you add
more bile into this area it dilutes and
it makes the bile flow real nicely
through there so
the bile that flows through here is
combined with bile acids and cholesterol
and so if there's too much cholesterol
and not enough bile acids
then you get this sludge but when you
increase this ratio
of more bile acids to the cholesterol
then it can flow a very good remedy
which i'm going to cover a little bit
more later
is tudka and tutka is a
type of bile salt that if you take it an
empty stomach a few times a day it can
open up the flow of this bile and get
rid of a lot of pain in this right upper
quadrant i also recommend that when you
eat food you take some bile salts after
you eat not before because it's alkaline
and we don't want to add an alkaline
thing before you eat we add it after and
that'll help the system build up more
bile so you can now have more bile to be
able to digest the fats now i will be
talking about what originally caused you
to be deficient about in the first place
but i want to kind of give you an
overview of everything first okay all
right so this is very common okay this
problem on the right side i had this
problem for about 12 years i had no idea
what it was
and boy did i suffer and unfortunately i
started taking antacids
and so one of the root causes of a lack
of bile okay a bile deficiency
is having weakened stomach acids you
just don't have enough hydrochloric acid
to trigger the bile production and with
me i was taking all these antacids right
that then i ended up with a gallbladder
problem so i started out with a stomach
issue okay a lot of bloating in my
stomach and then i ended up with a
gallbladder problem probably because of
the quantity of antacids i was taking at
the time
but eventually i ended up with an ulcer
so just so you know if you have an ulcer
there's a very specific way to correct
that you don't want to add more acid
but typically the biggest symptom for
the stomach if you don't have enough
acid is indigestion so you feel like the
food just is not being processed at this
level right in the center right here so
a simple remedy unless you have an ulcer
is betaine hydrochloride i will cover
that in a little bit as well as apple
cider vinegar now you also have to
realize
that the stomach has these acid sensors
that are connected with the valve on the
top
so if the stomach acid is not where it
should be between one and three which is
extremely acid
then this valve won't close and now
you're gonna start getting regurgitation
okay acid reflux
and you're gonna get heartburn and then
eventually you'll get an ulcer
so if you have heartburn or acid reflux
or gerd
but no ulcers
you want to take betaine hydrochloride
okay and you want to take like five of
those as a remedy
before a meal and then also apple cider
vinegar on a regular basis if you have
an ulcer you can't take apple cider
vinegar or obtain hydrochloride because
that's going to make it worse
you want to take
something else like chlorophyll
and zinc carnosine okay that's the
remedy for an ulcer that one of the best
foods for an ulcer is actually cabbage
cabbage has something in it that can
actually heal an ulcer but zinc also is
very effective
now if you have problems on the left
side right here the upper quadrant
it could be the pancreas that's coming
from this bio sludge or it could be that
you have been eating
like junk food and refined foods and
cooked foods for many many years
or you're a diabetic or a pre-diabetic
and because diabetes is a problem with
the pancreas
not only are you going to have problems
with the hormone insulin but you also
have problems with the other part of the
pancreas that releases
enzymes so you're not going to be able
to
release enough enzymes for digestion so
this is why diabetics usually always
have digestive issues i will cover what
to do about that potentially you could
have a spleen problem if it's on the
upper left hand side but that's rare
now if you have
pain in the mid part right here or the
right part or the left part and the
middle part and this is the belly button
right here so to the right of the belly
button to the left or right in the
center typically that's going to be some
type of inflammation in your gut and you
can label it as irritable bowel syndrome
diverticulitis celiac now if it's on the
right side of the left side potentially
it could be a kidney stone
and i'll show you what to do with that
but there's one more thing i want to
share with you there's something called
sibo small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth
this is a situation that usually is
caused because you don't have enough
stomach acid okay
and then you have certain microbes that
are starting to grow in your small
intestine where they really should be
mostly in the large intestine and so now
we have this competition with your food
where you have these microbes that are
eating the food as it comes down and
it's producing a lot of gas
one way to know if you have sibo is that
you feel worse you get more bloating
when you take probiotics as well as
fiber
so if you do have sibo you should not be
consuming any fiber in fact you should
probably go carnivore for a couple
months
and the same thing with the ibs because
people with inflammation the colon
cannot tolerate a lot of fiber now if
you have pain in the abdomen area within
the very lower part that could
potentially be a fibroid if you're
female or even a prostate enlargement
if you're a male if it's on the right
lower quadrant potentially could be the
appendix
that's rare but it could be
or it could be just some type of
inflammation in the lower right hand of
the large intestine now if you go on the
lower part on the right side and left
side if you're female
potentially could be an ovary issue now
just as a really quick thing
if you have issues with the ovaries or
the prostate
one really important thing to eliminate
from the diet is milk okay because milk
has all sorts of things that can
aggravate this because it can swell up
the ovaries because it has growth
hormones in it all right now let's zoom
out and take kind of a
an overall view of what's happening
and really what's missing okay when you
go to a doctor for help with with
abdominal pain they definitely do not
look at the connection or relationship
between various things and they
definitely omit the topic of food okay
they don't look at your diet enough
that's actually number two in the list
it's not the most important thing but
it's the second most important thing and
there's not a lot of emphasis on that
that important uh topic with food but
basically that's why we have digestive
organs to help you digest food we have
acid coming down from the stomach to
help you break down protein we have bile
from the gallbladder that helps you
break down fats enzymes from your
pancreas that help you break down
carbohydrates proteins and fats and we
also have enzymes from our small
intestine that help
break that down as well in fact 90 of
all the digestion occurs in the small
intestine
and then if anything doesn't get
digested primarily fibers the microbiome
your friendly bacteria
digest it in the large intestine now if
you can imagine let's say you are
deficient in hydrochloric acid you're
going to have heartburn what are you
going to be given
an antacid so now we're gonna treat low
hydrochloric acid with something to take
that last little bit that you have left
and remove that
that is going to make everything worse
because this is the start of the chain
of events that occurs all the way down
through here and so the person ends up
taking
stronger drugs and more drugs the more
that you're going to create a deficiency
in bile salts so now we don't have
enough bile salts
so then all the supplements you take
like the omega-3 fatty acids don't get
absorbed you don't get vitamin a d e and
k and we have all sorts of problems and
also one really important thing about
bile is the elimination of cholesterol
so now cholesterol kind of just stays up
into the liver and then you have all and
backs up into the arteries and you
create all sorts of issues so a couple
things with the stomach acid
antacids will deplete your hydrochloric
acid just aging will deplete your
hydrochloric acid a low salt diet will
deplete the hydrochloric acid and then
when we get to bile
what would create a bile deficiency well
number
one antacids right number two
not consuming enough fat the production
of bile is stimulated by eating dietary
fat so if you're a low-fat diet it's
going to dry up the bile salts now you
also have gastric bypass surgery would
do it
and this right here
when you have a lot of insulin or
insulin resistance
you start lowering
the bile pool or
accumulation or reserve that you have so
that's probably a very common cause now
estrogen let's say you're on birth
control pills let's say for example
you're pregnant
that's going to lower your bowel salts
this is why women that get pregnant
sometimes have gall stones because the
gallstone is created from lack of bile
antacids i just mentioned that steroids
as in prednisone or cortisone cream
things like that and also a fatty liver
because if you don't have the full
function of the liver you're not going
to produce the bile without bile you get
bloating and a lot of pain that goes up
on the right side right here and pain on
the upper right quadrant right here now
by fixing the bile problem by actually
taking bile salts or tutka
a lot of times you'll actually end up
helping the pancreas especially if it's
like pancreatitis or there's some
problem in this little duct
but the other big problem is people that
are consuming too many carbohydrates
have burnt out their pancreas or they
eat a lot of cooked foods
and what's in raw foods is enzymes so
when you cook everything especially
vegetables you destroy the enzymes and
you force your pancreas to work harder
and of course here's another big problem
antibiotics if you had an antibiotic
before
it destroys all the good bacteria and
now what happens is you're not going to
have as much help from the microbiome to
actually break down the fiber and you
can get all sorts of issues like
inflammation
and
deficiency of bile because guess what
your microbiome also makes
bile salts other common causes of
abdominal pain food allergies could be
dairy it could be nuts
it could be soy it could be egg
it could be gluten okay that's a real
common one or you can have a gluten
intolerance or you can have a lactose
intolerance in milk that's the milk
sugar or a gluten intolerance okay
that's the protein in certain grains or
just sensitivity to certain foods
it's not a true allergy but your body
just reacts to it also certain foods
have enzyme inhibitors okay especially
nuts okay
when you eat a lot of nuts or peanut
butter with enzyme inhibitors
that can irritate the gallbladder as
well and create pain underneath the
right rib cage versus if you were to
take those nuts and germinate them okay
soak them in water and dry them out you
would find a lot less discomfort in the
right upper quadrant then you have foods
that have anti-nutrients and that could
be oxalates like in spinach or phytates
in the grains or lectins in the
nightshade family of vegetables some
people are more sensitive to these than
other people but it's definitely
something to discuss and then this thing
right here is very very common consuming
things that are inflammatory and that
would be mainly the
omega-6 fatty acids the omega-3 are
anti-inflammatory and the omega-6 are
inflammatory so
unfortunately the omega-6 oils have
replaced the saturated fats as far as
the dietary guidelines so people are
consuming massive quantities of soy oil
corn oil canola cottonseed oil and it's
creating a lot of inflammation in their
guts
and then we get the fiber okay i'm not
talking about the fiber from vegetables
i'm talking about the fiber that is in
virtually
most foods nowadays they're putting
these synthetic fibers in these keto
bars and the keto snacks in so many
foods they're called functional fibers
they're synthetic fibers
even a certain type of maltodextrin is a
synthetic fiber you have dextrin itself
is a synthetic fiber then you have very
badly processed fiber like soluble corn
fiber soluble tapioca fiber
all these fibers are really irritating
the gut and causing a lot of pain and
you won't know it until you don't eat it
anymore and you'll say wow man my
stomach feels so much better
all right and this is the part you've
been waiting for okay the number one
cause
of your abdominal pain is not
necessarily what you're eating
it's just that you're eating too
frequently the frequency of eating is
literally cramming
so much food down our plumbing system
that the plumbing doesn't have a chance
to process the food it overwhelms the
whole system never letting the system
have a chance to reset or breathe
our bodies were not designed to graze
like a cow that has four stomachs okay
in fact i have like i think eight or
nine cows and a cow will graze
most of the day
and then they will sit down through the
day and regurgitate the grass coming up
and spend time to re-chew it and bring
it back with humans we don't do that
we're doing
snacks for the day
and at night it's a constant eating
right after dinner until you go to bed
so the amount of snacking is really the
big problem if you just stop the
snacking i would venture to say 80
percent of your digestive problems would
clear up immediately and it's called
intermittent fasting all right number
two is all about the foods that you're
eating they're the wrong foods grains
are the biggest culprit not just gluten
but grains in general that have all
sorts of things that create inflammation
in the body not to mention the seed oils
that are connected with the grains
highly inflammatory a lot of abdominal
pain you get rid of these and your
abdominal pain goes away and then you
have the third main cause which is a
side effect from antibiotics that then
leave you with all sorts of problems
as a cascade effect and as well as other
medications like antacids so in summary
if your pain is on the upper right
quadrant you take tuttle on an empty
stomach and then you would take
bile salts okay with your meals and i'm
going to put all this in the description
down below if your pain is in the middle
part right here retain hydrochloride
okay
unless you have an ulcer then if you
have pain on the upper left side you're
going to need more raw foods okay don't
cook your foods as much and it might
help to take an enzyme to help you as
well as decrease the insulin with the
diet that i'm going to recommend down
below if you have sibo garlic oregano
will help kill the microbes with
intermittent fasting very very important
if you have a kidney stone
you need a lot of lemon water and to
drink at least 2.5 liters of fluid every
single day and that will dilute your
urine enough so you really never develop
a stone even if you're susceptible to
getting stones all right if your pain is
in the lower part right here you need
probiotics you need fermented foods or
if there's a problem with a prostate
uterus or ovaries you need to eliminate
dairy all right now that you know that
now you need to start intermittent
fasting if you haven't seen my video on
that you need to check it out right here